that once a Jew goes to Najar Kalani who
was a judge he was rich
and a Jew a poor man comes and tells him
that your prophet said that this dunya
is like a jail imprisonment for the
believers and for unbelievers it's
paradise I'm poor my clothes are
tattered you're rich you're living a
luxurious life how can you explain this
hadith
said
Those believers who know what is waiting
for them in a that is Jenna. Even if
you're the richest man in this world,
all the happiness compared to Jana is
like compared to Jenna is like
imprisonment.
And if the unbelievers know
what is there for them in the hakira
hell and the lowest
the coolest fire in hell if it touches
your feet your brains will boil. If they
know where they will go, even if they
are the worst human being in this world,
for them this is Jenna.
This is explanation of the hadith of our
beloved prophet wasallam. So Jenna,
happiness is a state,
your belief, your mind.
And Allah says in the Quran
in surah bakar chapter number two verse
number 156
Allah says that
for the believers whenever there is any
calamity they say
to him we belong and to him we return.
Just a few days ago
there was a person who called me and
said shake
my father has been admitted into
hospital and heart attack. So I said
rajun HE SAID SHAKE MY FATHER HASN'T
DIED.
I said yes I know. WHY DID YOU SAY THAT?
I said brother in a Muslim ummah they
feel if someone dies we say this from
him we come and to whom we belong. When
anyone dies we say
yes we can say that but for any calamity
one of the calamities that okay but even
if someone is sick and you say that so
many people think okay do you want me to
die I say no no no I'm praying to Allah
so this is a misconception amongst some
of the Muslims wealth the Quran says is
a fitna fitna means test
so when you get rich don't be happy.
When you're rich, your test is more
difficult. IF YOU PASS, YOU GET A HIGHER
REWARD. THEREFORE, even the Sahabas who
are rich like Abdman Rhdan
may Allah be pleased with him before
entering he'll be questioned because
you're rich.
Therefore, I tell to all the rich
people, Allah has given you immense
wealth. Then make Allah your partner in
business.
And when you make Allah your partner,
you cannot make him a small partner.
Correct? Make him at least 51% partner.
So whatever you earn, at least give 51%
in charity. Then you are safe.
Generally the Islamic ruling is that if
you have wealth more than the nab level,
you have to give 2.5%. This is for every
rich person who is not a who's not a
who's not poor. Yes, give 2.5%. That is
the Sharia. But if you're extremely
rich,
this is my suggestion. It's not part of
the Sharia. It's my advice that if you
want TO BE SAFE, ALLAH HAS MADE YOU A
MILLIONAIRE.
Other people earning
maybe few hundred a month. You are
earning $50,000 a month, $100,000 a
month. What do you do? Make Allah your
partner.
Even if you give more than 50%, yet
you'll be multiple times richer than the
poor man.
When my son started business two years
back, I said, "My son, when you start
business, minimum 51% you give to Allah
subhanaa tala. Minimum. I'm a veteran,
so I give more. Afterwards, maybe you
can maybe compete with me or catch up
with me." Minimum.
The more you get, the more you receive.
So wealth is a fitna. Allah says in
surah tba chapter 9 verse number 34 and
35 that those who hold wealth and spend
it not in the way of Allah Allah will in
the hellfire and akar will brand you on
your forehead on your flanks and on your
back and Allah will say have the taste
of the wealth you hold it in what is
money and unfortunately for many of the
Muslims money is the most important
we started a dava organization which a
budget of $80 a month $1,000 a
I told my father you give so much
thousands of dollars in charity give me
$80 a month. He agreed. We started in
1991. In few years we became the largest
and had the biggest budget in the
private da in the world.
There's no private da in the world which
even has 10% of a budget because for us
money is NOT THE MOST IMPORTANT.
UNFORTUNATELY MOST OF THE MUSLIM
organization money is everything for
them. I say if money is important is the
least important. If 10 important things
are there, 10th is money. Not the first,
not the second, not the third, not the
fourth, not the fifth.
Wealth is a fitna. If Allah GIVES YOU
WEALTH, HOW YOU SPEND is important.